[Música]
y llegó el momento de actualizar la
información económica aquí en directo
América y por ello le doy la bienvenida
nuevamente a mi compañera Daniela
Blandón Daniela muy buenos días
nuevamente empezamos en Reino Unido
algunas empresas ya muestran beneficios
con una semana laboral de cuatro días
cómo es eso pues esto puede parecer un
experimento excéntrico de hecho sí es un
experimento pero no es tan excéntrico
porque hace parte de una serie de
pruebas que han llamado la atención de
economistas y de empresas que buscan
encontrar una solución a la
desaceleración del crecimiento de la
productividad que ha afectado a Reino
Unido y también a otras economías
occidentales en los últimos años sobre
todo cuando el Banco Central de
Inglaterra proyecta que en los próximos
años ese crecimiento de la productividad
será casi nulo este fabricante de
productos para el cuidado de la piel que
vamos a ver Five squirtles comenzó a
aplicar el pago de cinco días por cuatro
trabajados y ya ve los resultados dice
que sus ventas han subido en 40% en
apenas seis meses
las personas en una semana de cuatro
días están un poco más concentradas un
poco menos cansadas se concentran en
tareas individuales y por lo tanto
tienen menos distracciones
cometen menos errores y una gran parte
del trabajo que estábamos haciendo
anteriormente era corregir esos errores
algunos de ellos si no se detectaban
daban lugar a malas experiencias de los
clientes quejas devoluciones ahora los
eliminamos por completo pero Andrés no
una semana laboral de cuatro días sino
que también para mantener el rendimiento
la orden es no responder llamadas
ignorar los correos electrónicos y
desactivar la mensajería instantánea
durante 4 horas al día sacrificios que
hay que hacer Sí claro para tener un día
más de descanso exactamente Daniela
cambiamos de tema la Unión Europea tomó
la delantera en La regulación de los
criptoactivos esa es una regulación
Andrés que lleva años en la mirada de
las autoridades pero se volvió más
urgente después del colapso de la firma
de intercambio de ftx que es la segunda
o era la segunda del mundo y que llegó a
millonarias pérdidas para los
inversionistas las reglas que obtuvieron
hoy el visto bueno final en el seno de
la comisión europea son las primeras de
la industria a nivel mundial y en
esencia requieren que las empresas que
deseen emitir comerciar y salvaguardar
criptoactivos o también activos
toquenizados o monedas estables en el
bloque de los 27 países obtengan una
licencia también se les está exigiendo
que contribuyan con las autoridades para
evitar que este tipo de transacciones Se
use con fines de lavado de dinero o
también de financiación del terrorismo
con este conjunto de reglas aumentan las
presiones sobre países como Reino Unido
o Estados Unidos para que se pongan al
día con esa regulaciones vamos hacia
Estados Unidos Dani Hoy es un día clave
en las negociaciones sobre el techo de
deuda hemos venido hablando de esto
durante las últimas semanas por su
importancia para la economía del mundo y
es que el presidente Joe biden recibe en
la Casa Blanca Hoy a los líderes
demócratas y republicanos del congreso
para buscar un acuerdo que permita
evitar un deporte en dos semanas el
primero en la historia del país y de
cuyas consecuencias ha insistido la
secretaria del tesoro Janet yelen en
varias oportunidades que serían
catastróficas el mandatario se ha
mostrado optimista pero no lo está tanto
la oposición
Así que no no creo que estemos en un
buen lugar sé que no lo estamos es todo
ignorar el problema pensando que
desaparecerá podría abrir paso a un
incumplimiento como pasó en la frontera
si estuviéramos sentados en una
habitación como en la que estuvimos hoy
y fuera febrero Me sentiría bien al
respecto nuestra secretaria del tesoro
acaba de decir que el primero de junio
podríamos quedarnos sin dinero solo nos
quedan algunos días el presidente
decidió esperar 100 días antes de
negociar
y llegó el momento de conocer los
indicadores abrió
rojo con la expectativa desde luego
puesta sobre esta reunión y también
después de que Home Depot recordara su
perspectiva de ganancias y ventas para
el año porque Esto indica que hay un
cambio de tendencia en el gasto de los
estadounidenses en Europa las bolsas
operan al alza después de que la oficina
de estadísticas revelara que la economía
de los 20 países que conforman la Zona
Euro creció un tímido 0,1% en el primer
trimestre Comparado con el trimestre
anterior esquivando de esta manera una
temida recesión y en Asia los mercados
cerraron mixtos después de que los datos
mostraran que la economía china es más
débil de lo esperado su producción
industrial creció 5,6% interanual en
abril pero el mercado estaba esperando
un 10% mucho más Daniela Muchísimas
gracias a descansar y ya entonces nos
vemos mañana con más noticias económicas
mañana